it's Friday follies and tonight's theme
interrupting business as usual joining
us now with all the details Raymond
Arroyo Fox News contributor New York
Times bestselling author of the
brand-new phenomenal book will Wilder
and the Amulet of power
Raymond alright there are a few
high-profile examples of reporters
getting more than they bargained for and
yeah in the field so what happened
casting Corporation reporter Chris
Grover was live at a Toronto comedy club
this week when behind him actor Boyd
banks approached and watch they are
hoping that this town hall will stop
this transition to Just for Laughs from
happening but things are getting a
little awkward out here so I'm gonna
pass it back to you what a jerk the
sukkah raved on his neck he labelled on
his ear he now has come up with a
statement banks the actors can't you
immediately defend yourself well I would
think you could knock on the mouth he
says he needs treatment for his mental
health issues now this happens far more
frequently than people are aware a
reporter he filed a police report and
banks the actor with the active tongue
he claims that he's guilty for
everything and like Smollett he has
mental health issues no no that's the
convenient go to more ridiculous now
Laura there are some journalists who
picked up things they never intended not
only creeps like this guy ed O'Keefe
over at CBS this week was posted outside
the Cohen hearing room and an unaware
young man didn't know he was live on TV
participate actually winning the job and
you can sit there and say yeah but this
is an uncredible witness because he had
was saying one thing just a few months
ago oh my gosh he stopped striking here
a friend of mine saying Americans eat in
public like this like it in an awful
awful but you know Laura sadly too many
people think that reporters are their
playthings because they see them on TV
so they engage they either relaxed
around them or they think they can do
the silly thing where they touch
or hit them or punch them my hero my
all-time hero when it comes to hazing in
the field and dealing with these hazers
is our own Mike Tobin note the smooth
technique ten seconds later the second
explosion goes off according to the FBI
at the location where he dropped his
please don't do that where he dropped
the where he dropped his knapsack police
don't do that without missing a beat no
no no he's strong comes up to touch you
you can just do a quick elbow if they
touch you yes a touch you know knock
back Adam II Award winner Jennifer
Lawrence Laura stars in a new film
called unbreaking America I don't know
about the grammar there but we'll take
it
it is a celebrity PSA that is supposed
to acquaint the audience with the
corruption in the government and what
they can do about it how do we unwritten
I'm obsessed with this idea as you can
see here nearly half of American voters
are now registered independent and then
there is gerrymandering with politicians
drawing the boundaries of their own
voting districts into crazy shapes that
it all adds up to this vast ring of
influence over our elected leaders it's
a corrupt system in which we the people
have near zero influence over our own
government and that is sad that is not
the country I feel like I grew up in
well what country did you think you grew
up in here's what she's actually
advocating she's advocating a bill an
anti-corruption bill okay and it's
pretty radical this group represent us
represent us wants to ban candidates
from accepting lobbyist money they want
to end gerrymandering they want
automatic voter registration and at home
voting Laura and they'd like to
overthrow the electoral college yeah
this ending corruption Act is actually
itself an act of corrupt but she says
not what she says there's a silver
lining in that playbook well she's it
looks more to me like an American hustle
I can do Game of Thrones
is that what she was you know Hunger
Games Hunger Game whatever